whether you love it hate it or never
thought about it chances are some nanny
wants to banish presenting the nanny of
the month runners-up the FDA for
requiring new more graphic potentially
counterproductive warnings on cigarette
packs in the city of San Francisco's
Animal Control Commission which wants to
ban the sale of a pet fish I think it
really depends so a lot of tropical fish
aren't endangered the ban would include
all pets even goldfish but the nanny of
the month comes from Montgomery County
Maryland a County inspector find them
$500 forget this operating a lemonade
stand without a permit he's the
inspector in his boss
aka the nanny in charge said their goal
was protecting the safety of people to
move sparked outrage in the county later
waived the fine but pint-sized
entrepreneurs across America are facing
shakedowns people are so outraged in her
wouldn't they just ask Clementine in New
York Julie and Oregon or Daniela in
California who pled her case to the City
Council after getting busted check back
next month for more examples of
busybodies minded your own business they
kept saying oh no you can't do this